revenge is sweet especially if you've
been waiting for it for a long time if
you clicked on this video you probably
want to know about the revenge stories
where the lead hero goes down the dark
path blurring the line between right and
wrong through actions that are pretty
much questionable from burning your
enemy to a crisp and taking over an
entire Empire let's find out the top 10
most satisfying Revenge moments in anime
now who can forget this one classic
moment Shikamaru defeats Hidan in Naruto
[Music]
this tactical prowess and ability to
devise intricate plans make him a
formidable asset in battles and critical
situations and in one crucial moment he
proved himself a strategic Prodigy when
he got revenge on Hidan the one who
killed his Sensei since Hidan is
Immortal Shikamaru thought of a
brilliant strategy if you can't kill
Hidan he'll just go ahead and bury him
alive this scene made every OG anime fan
go wild it's not only full of nostalgia
but the way he Dan fell for it was worth
the wait Shikamaru made him his own
grave and even used asumar's lighter to
light the explosions it's at 1 000 IQ
plan that worked out in the end because
in shikamaru's own words if you curse
someone be prepared to dig your own
grave
foreign
let me ask you a question do you get
sick of looking at the same boring anime
character designs and animation in every
jrpg and Anime game you play are you
looking for a better gaming experience
with a unique art style well check out
dislike dislike is a free stylish Urban
mythical RPG and not only that it's an
ongoing series of urban myth comics
where in an alternate futuristic
Universe the world was turned upside
down after huge portal-like structures
called Miracles arrived as Pandora's Box
opened individuals called espers were
granted Divine powers to defeat the
monsters that wanted to destroy the
world best of all these abilities came
from ancient mythical beings like Gods
from Greek Norse Chinese Egyptian and
even Japanese folklore these diverse and
unique characters have their own stories
that are beautifully portrayed in the
urban myth Comics which uses a
captivating R Star based on Cell
animation if that's not enough there are
constant updates and with each new
update dislike releases new characters
with their own unique stories and right
now they have a brand new exciting
limited time event within the game which
allows you to take a look at xiaotu's
story as one of the Chinese gods after
she acquired Divine Powers her fate
takes a turn for the worst as she
becomes stuck in a never-ending cycle of
constantly living a summer day
participate in the various summer themed
events to earn massive rewards support
my channel by downloading dislike from
the link in the description below or
scan the QR code on the screen join
dislike today and use my code fight with
Gods to get 5 free draws and massive
in-game rewards fight with gods and
fight for infinite possibilities next on
a list of revenge stories that will make
you think the world is healing again we
have now fumi's Quest For Justice
against multi-s Mel remark in the rising
of The Shield Heroes
foreign
[Music]
quickly became the epitome of a villain
and scum making viewers eagerly await a
well-deserved punishment as she betrayed
null for me by lying that he harassed
her now for me's revenge against multi
is a tale of redemption and Triumph over
betrayal but we all know we wanted to
see a head get chopped off in this
moment with the help of the queen malty
finally got what she deserved along with
the King all her lies were exposed and
every time she tried to lie again she
got electrified we just wish she could
have lied more as the shield hero now
for me faced constant oppression and
false accusations planned by multi but
instead of giving up now for me showed
resilience and resourcefulness what
makes this Revenge so satisfying is
seeing the tables turn for multi where
her power was stripped off along with
the Kings now for me's actions not only
dismantled her Web of Lies but also
demonstrated his growth as a character
witnessing Maltese downfall is a
gratifying experience especially now
that they have new nicknames
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
a show where your concerns aren't
limited to towering Titans alone but
also the complex politics will make your
head hurt
[Music]
s Zeke and Levi had one of the most
frustrating and sad rivalries that made
one of the hypest speeches in the entire
history of anime and one of the saddest
scenes in the series and just when Levi
finally gave Zeke the beat down he
deserved it was awesome Z killed Irwin
along with the Scout recruits and if
that wasn't enough injected his spinal
fluid into the wines of Levi's comrades
back in season four with just one scream
Levi became even more depressed as he
was now surrounded by his former
comrades turned Titans Levi's brutality
was switched to Max as he was forced to
do something the Zeke didn't even
imagine he was capable of it was just so
satisfying to see how frustrated Zeke
was it was even better when we saw Levi
Trash Talk Zeke's messed up face after
he blew him up with one Thunder spear
after all that pain Levi finally got his
comeback for real
foreign
[Music]
with politics that could mess up even
America today but we're not here to talk
about the anime we're here to talk about
one of the most satisfying moments in
the show the scene where Lelouch takes
the Throne of Britannia after killing
his own father Lelouch uses his gears to
control every last Noble in front of him
he sits on britannia's throne in front
of every noble within the Empire and
straight up declares himself the king of
the world in a live broadcast what makes
this moment so satisfying is that we
have to remember what Lelouch went
through after being exiled to Japan and
suffering Untold trauma we can't help
but grin as we see each and every noble
lose it Lelouch even for the Black
Knights after suzaku comes in to save
him because betrayal doesn't choose a
side literally this scene cements just
how much of a genius he is and how he's
also a Calamity class threat the music
helps to make this even better because
that classic battle Symphony doesn't
miss a beat and all of this is just the
beginning
is your majesty
[Music]
now let's shift our attention to an
entry that has a very questionable scene
from an equally questionable anime yes
this is redo of healer kiaru's payback
to Flair
[Laughter]
kyaru being a Healer was exploited again
and again by others he was also held
captive by Flair princess of the giral
Kingdom who abused and mentally tortured
him however using his healing magic
kiaru went back four years into the past
and got his revenge on Flair after years
of torture at the hands of his so-called
allies kyaru managed to break free and
get his hands on the Philosopher's Stone
then goes back in time and leaves no
stone unturned to get his revenge
princess Flair was mentally and
physically tortured by him the payback
against Flair was undoubtedly satisfying
in more ways than one for him and we
have to remember that torture kiaru went
through that bore him to do such brutal
acts after being tortured for years and
suffering alone we can't help but side
with him even if he's looking like the
villain the scene is definitely not for
everyone especially kids and it doesn't
get any better as the anime moves
forward it definitely caused a lot of
controversy but both the author and the
studio just don't care now this is what
I call a true Revenge moment online
foreign
something about JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
is really well bizarre
[Applause]
how many people talk about this anime
and it's bang a part where each JoJo
gets involved in a typical JoJo mess and
deals with the creepiest villains
hermes's revenge for his sister Gloria
is one hell of a memorable and
satisfying Revenge moment in JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure Stone Ocean hermes's
Story in stone ocean did feel a bit
familiar because polander's story from
Stardust Crusaders also revolved around
avenging their sister's death after
Sports Max killed hermes's sister Gloria
he threw her body in a gutter even after
such a horrendous act he only received a
five-year sentence and so Hermes commits
robbery to get herself inside the prison
in order to avenge her sister's unfair
death when Hermes Falls Sports Max she
drowned him in a sewage pipe and
eventually beat him to death while
teaming up with FF and Joe Lynn and
every hit was for Gloria makes this
Revenge so satisfying well it's nothing
more than star Max finally being
tortured inside the tight pipes of the
prison with little air to breathe and
dying in the most miserable way possible
[Music]
foreign
s when two men fall for the same girl
murder and betrayal while as dark as it
might sound yet Cowboy Bebop introduces
one of its most iconic moments where
Spike Spiegel Avengers Julia's death
in a twist of fate Spike wants a close
companion and Ally of vicious within the
crime syndicate finds himself entangled
in a love triangle with vicious's
girlfriend Julia unfortunately in one
moment Julia dies after vicious sends
Hitman after them in the end Spike
finally got his revenge after facing
vicious in one of the most memorable
fights in anime what makes this Revenge
so fulfilling is the Deep rooted history
and complex relationship between Spike
and vicious vicious and Spike duke it
out and Spike succeeds in shooting him
but he's also seriously injured another
thing that makes this moment so
satisfying is How It Ends the show it's
cemented Cowboy Bebop as a classic and
legendary show in the anime sphere
because of its sad yet great ending the
animation might look a bit old but we
can't doubt the intensity and impact
this scene had best of all we don't know
if Spike survived or not and it shows
that Revenge always comes at a price
bad
this is another classic moment that
pushed Hunter Hunter into one of the
best series of all time
in the world of Hunter Hunter the
climactic moment arrives when gone
freaks driven by an unwavering desire
for vengeance confronts Pito one of the
Fearsome Chimera ants responsible for
the death of kite this long-awaited
showdown carries immense weight and
emotional intensity the reason behind
gone's thirst for revenge is deeply
rooted in his fondness for kite
witnessing the brutal death of his
mentor figure at the hands of nephepito
ignites a fire with him gone and this
fire made nephepita regret everything
with his Newfound strength he bashed
Pizza like a doll and just wouldn't stop
this Revenge moment wasn't just
satisfying but also sad as we saw a new
side to God the music was fantastic and
the animation to represent gone's rage
was out of this world it was brutal and
the way gone did everything just to get
revenge made everyone feel all kinds of
emotions
[Music]
you thought that time I got reincarnated
as the Slime was all rainbows well think
again because in this scene all hell
breaks loose
throughout the series River encounters
heavy enemies or finds himself in a dire
situation that requires the usage of his
most potent abilities as a result of
rimaru's growth and the acquisition of
powerful abilities manifested some truly
devastating skills after Tempest was
attacked by humans and some of their
citizens massacred rimaru decides to
take revenge in one Heavenly attack
every single soldier in the enemy's Camp
was taken out excluding the king and the
wizard the sound effects while the music
suddenly disappeared helped him making
the attack more epic and the way they
did the animation was one of the best in
the series not a single one of us
expected how devastating this attack
would become where even the death toll
countdown had us on the edge of our
seats this is a legendary scene that
took Everyone by surprise and it was so
satisfying to watch rimaru finally take
his revenge without holding back
[Music]
and at number one in our list of the top
10 most satisfying Revenge moments is a
scene that gets included in every
Revenge list Roy Mustangs Vengeance
against Envy in Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood
[Music]
after May's Hughes was killed by Envy
Roy is now full of anger and just wants
revenge when fate finally gives Roy a
chance he meets Envy hoop after getting
shot an uncountable amount of times and
is now weakened tries to insult him but
gets engulfed in flames right away every
time Roy snaps Envy is surrounded by a
huge Fireball just like how Shikamaru
ended he done this was another
satisfying moment that anime fans can't
seem to get enough of the way Roy kept
attacking Envy without any moment of
doubt and how each snap of his fingers
made Envy scream was a sight to see
there's not much to say other than Roy
Mustang's Vengeance against Envy
deserves the top spot on our list
and those are some of the most
satisfying moments in anime when
characters got their revenge and don't
forget to subscribe smash that like
button and click the notification Bell
for more videos like this one once again
don't forget to check out dislike links
in the description